I'm not sure how much you could tease  about season two but given how Emily's  mind frame has changed and where she's  landed at the end of the season is that  going to affect the tone of season two  at all yes absolutely I think in season  one we have seen sort of glimpses of  what we'll definitely see a lot more of  and season two as far as again.i we have  to imagine that at some point in Emily's  life she sat at that desk right and only  wrote these poems for who she wanted to  see them but there were also there had  to have been moments where she wanted  the world she'd we know that where she  wanted the world to see her work and  hear and read and appreciate her work  and her Worth and we definitely go into  exploring you know she says at the end  of season one I am a poet and this is  what I'm gonna do whether you like it or  not and she takes that to another level  season two so I can't wait